Of course, multiple processors can arrive at the barrier at the same
time and all of them are going to work with their local data
structure. So, like, this guy will work with this local data structure.
This guy with this local data structure. With this local data structure. And
each of them is waiting for his partner to arrive so that
he can move up the tree. So that's what going on and so
eventually, P3 is going to arrive and so when P3 arrives, he decrements
the count, sees it as zero so he can move up the tree.
When it comes here it says, oh the count is
already one so I decrement it and the count becomes
zero and remember P0 decremented the count and it is
waiting on locksense. So P3, when it comes here, finds
that the count is one, decrements it, becomes zero and
it moves up the tree because the barrier is still
not done until we know that everybody has arrived at
the barrier. So in the meanwhile, on this half of the
tree, what's going on is that P4 has arrived, P5 is
not there yet, P6 and P7 have arrived. And it turns
out that P6 was the last guy to come to the
barrier here, and therefore, he is the guy that has moved up.
And he has decremented count. And he's waiting for this half
of the tree to arrive at the barrier. And you can guess
which one is going to come up, right? Because P4 has already
arrived here, and so if P4 has already arrived here, he's decremented
the count, and he's waiting on locksense to flip. So
the straggler in this whole seam, scheme of things, is
this guy right here. He's the guy who is, is
still not arrived, but eventually he'll also arrive. When he
arrives, he will decrement the count, find that the count
has become zero, move up the tree, and he'll find
that this count is already decremented also, and when he
comes up here, he will decrement it to zero, and
then he'll say, oh, if we're all done, so we
can move up here. So, that's what is going to happen. So
we come here, P5 comes here and goes all the
way up. And then when it comes up here, it sees
that P3 has already decremented the count to one. And
so when he comes up, he decrements it, and it becomes
zero. And at this point, everybody has arrived at the
barrier. So let's understand what each processor does. When a processor
arrives at a barrier it is going to decrement the count. If the count is
not zero, it's going to spin on this locksense flag. If a
processor arrives at a barrier, decrements the count, finds that the count
is zero, then what it's going to do is
one of two things. The first thing it's going to
do is, he's going to say, do I have a parent? If I have a parent, what I have to
do is, I have to recurse. Do the same
thing to the next level. Right? So, so the algorithm
is, decrement count and see if the count becomes
zero. If the count has become zero, then you recurse.
If end of the parent is there, you recurse.
If the count does not become zero, then spin on
the local locksense flag. And you continue this. So you
continue this P0, that this came up here and informed
this is another parent. So so this, you know, it, it
is, it is, it is stuck here. But P3, when it
came later on, it moves up. And when it came up
here, this is the last part. So there's no more recursing here.
So when P5 finally arrives here, it finds that there is
no more parent. This is the root of the tree. And
since we reached the root of the tree, you know that
if the count is zero now at the root of the tree,
then everybody has arrived at the barrier. So count at
the root of the tree becoming zero is indicative to the
last arriving processor, P5 in this case, that everybody has arrived
at the barrier, so it's time now to wake up everyone.